PewDiePie shared recently his addiction
struggles he said that he was drinking
to escape emotions and that that was a
recipe for a disaster he said I used to
drink whiskey every single day and I
realized I was getting addicted when I
tried to cut it down and how difficult
that was substance abuse you know a few
years back I struggled with the same
thing I was drinking two to three beers
a night every night for a long run and I
wasn't at my best but when PewDiePie was
making that video I could relate so much
because he was talking about the
emotional pressure it was for emotional
Escape it was for not being able to
handle whether it's expectations real or
imagined this is what causes especially
played out to the extreme this is what
causes businesses to fail